en cálculo de una variable nosotros
siempre partimos de una función f x
verdad que si nosotros queremos
maximizar la o minimizar la entonces el
procedimiento general es calcular su
primera derivada verdad y la igualamos a
0 verdad entonces aquellos puntos que
satisfacen esta relación es en donde
podrían estar máximos o mínimos verdad y
lo que esto significa gráficamente es
que si nosotros tenemos la gráfica de
alguna función entonces la derivada
igual a cero significa que la recta
tangente a los puntos en donde esto
ocurre verdad es justamente horizontal y
aquí podemos ver que tenemos dos de
estos puntos digamos vamos a llamarle a
este punto x 1 y vamos a llamarle a este
otro punto x 2 verdad entonces de
simplemente considerar la primera
derivada igualada 0 no podemos
determinar si son máximos verdad
necesitamos un criterio que nos diga si
estos dos puntos son máximos
si son puntos mínimos verdad y si si tú
ves la gráfica en realidad es muy fácil
ver por supuesto que aquí tenemos un
punto máximo y aquí tenemos un mínimo
verdad pero si no le estuviéramos viendo
entonces necesitamos un criterio que te
diga la respuesta y en realidad esto es
muy sencillo verdad porque aquí podemos
ver que la gráfica es cóncava hacia
abajo es decir que la segunda derivada
es negativa en cambio de este lado
tenemos que la segunda derivada es
positiva verdad entonces con esto
podemos ver que si la concavidad es
hacia abajo tendremos un máximo verdad y
eso está relacionado con la segunda
derivada en cambio si la concavidad es
hacia arriba entonces tendremos un
mínimo y por supuesto tenemos el caso en
que la segunda derivada sea cero y en
este caso tenemos algo indeterminado es
imposible sólo con esta segunda derivada
a decidir si es máximo o si es mínimo
así que uno tendría que buscar algún
otro tipo de criterio para poder
determinar
y en el mundo de las funciones de varias
variables tendremos algo muy similar
tendremos algo muy similar entonces
digamos que tenemos una función de
varias variables digamos una f que
depende de dos variables digamos x
entonces para encontrar máximos o
mínimos ya sabemos que puede haber
puntos y ya nos tenemos que fijar en el
gradiente df y tenemos que igualarlo al
vector cero por eso es que lo estoy
digamos rellenando como si fuera en
negritas verdad y esto corresponde por
supuesto a hallar planos tangentes de
verdad y si a lo mejor esto no te suena
familiar o no lo recuerdas mucho te
recomiendo que veas los vídeos sobre
puntos máximos mínimos y puntos y allá y
el objetivo de este vídeo será ver cuál
es el análogo al criterio para la
segunda derivada en funciones de varias
variables verdad cómo podríamos
determinar si es un máximo o si es un
mínimo o si es un punto sí ya sólo
utilizando la información de la de la
función verdad entonces podremos llegar
a este crit
al final del vídeo pero antes de todo
esto en esta primera parte quiero ver un
ejemplo de cómo hallar los puntos en
donde el gradiente de la función se
anula para tener fórmulas concretas y la
función que estamos viendo del lado
izquierdo en realidad esta es la gráfica
de una función y esta función es x
cuarta menos 4x cuadrada
y cuadrada muy bien entonces esta es la
función que estamos graficando del lado
izquierdo muy bien y si nosotros
queremos encontrar los puntos en donde
el gradiente se anula esto significa que
queremos encontrar aquellos en donde la
derivada parcial de la función f con
respecto de x en el punto que estamos
por encontrar verdad esto tiene que ser
igual a 0 y lo mismo debe pasar con las
con la derivada parcial de f con
respecto de liberdade entonces esto por
supuesto evaluado en los puntos que
queremos encontrar verdad esto debe ser
igual a 0 y esa es la forma digamos
desarrollada de decir que el gradiente
se tiene que anular en esos puntos
verdad así que vamos a hacerlo
explícitamente esto en realidad nos dará
un sistema de ecuaciones que hay que
resolver muy bien entonces vamos a
calcular explícitamente estas derivadas
parciales y lo que tenemos es que si
queremos derivar esto con respecto de x
esto es el único este es
estos son los términos que dependen de x
verdad
esto nos dará 0 y si derivamos con
respecto de x tendremos 4x cúbica menos
8x verdad y esto es lo que queremos que
sea igual a cero por otro lado si
derivamos esto con respecto de y solo en
esta parte aparece ya y la derivada es 2
y esto queremos que sea igual a 0 muy
bien y en realidad este ejemplo resultó
ser bastante simple verdad de hecho
tenemos dos ecuaciones una para x y otra
para y pero bueno en general pueden
pasar cosas muchísimo más raras podría
ser que aquí tengamos términos también
que dependan de y quizás aquí podríamos
tener cosas que dependan de x en fin
esto puede complicarse tanto como uno
quiera verdad entonces para ir
resolviendo esta ecuación podríamos o
este sistema de ecuaciones podríamos
tomar esta primera expresión que es muy
simple de aquí obtenemos que jett tiene
que ser igual a cero muy bien en cambio
si nosotros tomamos esta expresión
quizás lo que nos conviene al inicio es
factorizar tanto como podamos por
ejemplo podríamos factorizar
4x verdad 4x si multiplica a x cuadrada
nos da 4x cúbica y luego restamos 2 para
que al multiplicarlo nos dé menos 8x
verdad y esto es lo que tiene que ser
igual a cero entonces tenemos un
producto de números que nos da cero
quiere decir que alguno de estos tiene
que ser cero entonces x tiene que ser
cero ese es una posible solución o bien
x cuadrada menos 2 tiene que ser cero de
aquí tendría que ser x más o menos la
raíz cuadrada de 2 para que al elevarlo
al cuadrado nos dé 2 y al restarle 2 nos
dé 0 muy bien entonces de aquí podemos
ver que tenemos tres soluciones 3 para x
y siempre tiene que ser cero verdad eso
nos da tres puntos en nuestro espacio de
dos dimensiones verdad vamos a poner
vamos a poner esos puntos explícitamente
podríamos tener x igual a cero igual a
cero podríamos tener x igual a raíz de 2
ye igual a 0 o podríamos tener x igual a
menos la raíz de 2 y igual a 0 verdad lo
que significa es que si nos fijamos en
la gráfica todos estos puntos tienen
planos tangentes paralelos al plano xy
así que por ejemplo podríamos verificar
justamente esto para el punto 0,0 viendo
desde adentro de la gráfica verdad y de
hecho viendo la gráfica podemos ver que
este punto el 0 0 es un punto silla en
realidad no puede verse ni como un
máximo ni como un mínimo verdad en
cambio los otros dos podemos ver aquí
que este pues se ve como si fuera x
igual a raíz de 2 y aquí tenemos x igual
a menos raíz de 2 y ambos son mínimos en
realidad no podríamos haber determinado
cuál era su valor x verdad si no
hubiéramos hecho estas cuentas así que
de aquí sale la siguiente pregunta si
nosotros no hubiéramos tenido la gráfica
como podríamos saber si el punto cero
cero edad puntos y allá
terminar que los otros son puntos son
mínimos verdad entonces lo que vamos a
hacer en este vídeo sólo para hacer un
calentamiento de del criterio de la
segunda derivada es tratar de seguir la
idea de cálculo de una variable y es
tomar las segundas derivadas parciales
para ver cómo influye la concavidad de
la gráfica así que vamos a considerar
las segundas derivadas parciales
entonces vamos a hacerlo por aquí vamos
a considerar la segunda derivada parcial
de f con respecto de x ambas veces
entonces eso corresponde a derivar esta
expresión verdad así que si derivamos
con respecto de x tendremos 12 x
cuadrada menos 8 muy bien 12 x cuadrada
menos 8 y en términos de la gráfica si
nos movemos solamente en la dirección de
x y cortamos digamos con un plano de
constante verdad e igual a constante
entonces vemos esta curva que es la de
la intersección y esta expresión nos
dice la concavidad en cada punto de esta
curva
pensemos justamente en los puntos que
nos interesan x igual a más raíz de dos
o menos raíz de dos va a ser exactamente
lo mismo entonces esto si nosotros
evaluamos en este punto tendríamos 12 x
raíz de 2 elevado al cuadrado que es 2
menos 8 verdad entonces aquí vemos que
podíamos poner más raíz de dos o menos
raíz de 2 y daba lo mismo porque
elevamos al cuadrado entonces 12 por 2
son 24 menos 8 es 16 esto es 16 y esto
es un valor positivo es decir tenemos
concavidad hacia arriba en ambos casos
de verdad por lo tanto estos se tienen
que ver como mínimos muy bien así que
ahora vamos a analizar el otro caso no
cuando tenemos x igual a raíz de dos
sino cuando tenemos x igual a cero
verdad en este caso vamos a tener 12 x 0
al cuadrado así que vamos a poner aquí
a borrar también esto entonces tendremos
12 por 0 que nos da 0 menos 8 nos da
menos 8 entonces esto nos da un valor
negativo lo cual hace que la concavidad
sea hacia abajo y entonces se tiene que
ver como un máximo muy bien vamos a
anotar estos resultados por acá abajo
entonces si nos movemos en la dirección
de x este punto se va a aparecer a un
máximo este se va a aparecer a un mínimo
y el último también se parece a un
mínimo
qué pasa si ahora nos movemos en la
dirección únicamente de iu entonces
vamos a ver esto rápidamente con la
segunda derivada parcial con respecto de
y es verdad entonces si nosotros
calculamos la segunda derivada parcial
de f con respecto de i ambas veces
entonces simplemente hay que derivar
esta expresión y eso nos da simplemente
dos verdad que siempre es la misma
constante y es positivo siempre eso
implica que hay una concavidad hacia
arriba en todos lados verdad en la en la
gráfica esto significa que hay
concavidad hacia arriba y aquí sólo puse
el plano digamos x igual a cero pero en
realidad puedes imaginar que que puedes
mover este plano y siempre se va a tener
exactamente lo mismo entonces en todos
estos puntos vamos a tener mínimos
verdad
entonces aquí moviéndonos en la
dirección lleva a ser mínimo aquí
también va a ser mínimo aquí va a ser
mínimo así que con esto podría resultar
bastante tentador que con esto digamos
podríamos decir que 0 0 justamente es un
punto silla porque hay una diferencia
entre movernos en la dirección x y en la
dirección de verdad por un lado se ve
como un máximo y por un lado se ve como
un mínimo que es justamente lo que ya
habíamos encontrado que era un punto
silla en cambio en los otros dos casos
verdad tenemos que coinciden en que son
mínimos y es muy tentador pensar que por
eso tienen que ser mínimos pero en
realidad esto no basta resulta que este
este método no basta porque por ejemplo
no sé por qué podríamos dar ejemplos en
donde si hiciéramos este mismo
procedimiento podríamos llegar a una
conclusión falsa y la razón principal de
por qué esto no basta es porque
necesitamos considerar también la
información de la segunda derivada
parcial que nos hace falta es decir la
segunda derivada de
pero las derivadas cruzadas verdad es
decir primero con respecto de equis y
luego con respecto de y esta es la
información que nos falta en este
análisis y nosotros veremos el criterio
de la segunda derivada en toda su gloria
en el siguiente vídeo considerando
también este término es decir dando
cierta intuición de por qué este término
es relevante nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo